want to bring you some live pictures now  this is boston lincoln's show where  we know that a nine-year-old  girl  has  been killed  yesterday evening as lilia valutiti  she died on fountain lane yesterday  evening as a result of what we believe  to be a stab wound our thoughts continue  to be with lilia's family and friends  and we're doing everything that we can  to support them in what is a truly  devastating incident  we're still working through a number of  lines of inquiry we have specialist  officers and detectives working around  the clock to ensure we can progress our  investigations as quickly as we can  we're still appealing for members of the  public to get in touch if they haven't  already done so by calling 101 and  quoting incident number 419 of  yesterday's date the 28th of july or  they can report anonymously via crime  stoppers  people who are wanting to leave tributes  can do so at the corner of fountain lane  and fountain place thank you